were so full podcast welcome to the were
so full podcast with Felipe Esparza
Rodrigo Torres in Lisa Esparza yes right
what's up fool
and welcome back to our podcast we had
an awesome week we traveled the world
and yeah yeah yeah
got back doing it up watching a lot of
television oh man we went through we
went through the episode the whole
season of college friends friends of
college friends was from college shit's
bad without Jordan Peele
he gave my cookie yeah yeah a crazy mom
keegan-michael key Jordan Peele there
you go how about the first time we
started watching those videos dogs those
little snippets which was I will
remember that one famous Jordan Peele
and that keep he'll appeal yeah well no
we watch that the first time I showed me
that video of those fools in the
airplane when they did that sketch fool
yeah Keegan Keegan Michael key ghen
Michael Z - in that name right somebody
messed around because I know he's
adopted right yeah yeah [ __ ] all that
what's up with the show dog show for
like 30 something you guys have to watch
it
what about how above us man like like
put my headphones my others - man where
these people get that magic scare lady
they're happy where she would like that
the main actually she said I'm by
ourselves that about myself a 40th
birthday present 40 yeah yeah that will
holder for everybody we gotta be older
than 40 she breaks he's probably pushing
50 so like 48 maybe right she's gotta be
older than me not that far from the one
you're talking about the skinny skinny
skinny the one
having an affair with what's-her-name is
Middle Eastern absorbs it
no but anyways yeah there you go but
yeah she does look a little a little a
little a little accordion dog baby
accordion so water
what's accordion you know when your skin
goes your skin will - oh yeah my teacher
I trip is speaking about accordion fish
skin right yeah you always cause a
teacher man in third grade mr. Phil
annoy she was putting on my I'll see you
back a bar growing up you know we made a
lotta bomb
I met some people at the show who are
teachers and they were telling me and
you know no I when I was taping at the
end Boyle Heights the girl some girl was
talking to she's a fan she told me she's
a teacher that's I thinking about it
growing up I had no Latino teachers not
one in my neighborhood they were all
white or black or Asian what about the
one who did they run to the hills mr.
rout oh he wasn't well yeah he was a I
don't know if you were Mexican American
but he let they were root for you
leaders I'm sure yeah no I never say he
was Mexican though but he was probably
Latino he was down for the car he was
down bro he was there for day they Ohio
who the kids day would that happen it
can't
he left one must have been old in that
should happen in 68 right Kent State the
[ __ ] yeah that same time in Mexico City
what about Dennis or juniors so no bro
bidding growing up all my teachers I
couldn't even bother they were all white
uh-huh 1970 1970 yeah yeah so I guess he
was teaching now 16 years when I met I
was 15 years teaching US history his
story but yeah I don't know where all
your chicken or Mexican
yeah dude my principal my first
principal was mr. Mejia he had a PhD
then my third grade teacher class was a
lot miss Garcia who was a being this
person like his we're talking about but
that's the thing about no no there was
our teachers there - my second street
that were Latino
thanks again but then I came up miss my
teacher mr. Cordero you have Portuguese
there you go funny as hell
he was a great teacher what he said is
the crowd about about our they are a
unified history or any district when you
have a great teacher they make him up
principal oh yeah man and then he has to
call shots but nobody follows it what
his rules he was better he was better as
a teacher bro everybody tell me was a
joker but they always take that how come
they do that take all the good teacher
to make him up offers people welcome the
people this teachers want to move on old
when they were young you know cuz won't
the pays better and that's why they keep
going that one woman that was at Isaac's
charter school she started as his third
grade teacher the next year she was
assistant principal kept taking seminars
and like classes and certifications and
stuff all summer and then I think she's
running another school somewhere now
like that's what she wanted she was very
aggressive about it but they want to get
out of their class I remember like in
the 80s
nothing really able late 80s there was
like a lot of a lot of movies coming out
to make teachers look bad
oh yeah they're like losers or they'll
make them look like we're showing their
real life but they're making the school
of bad like you know like lean on me or
the other though that was fun that was
you said that was when you were telling
teachers oh my god I was thinking about
that woman you were talking about it
never seen it hilarious bro
this was hilarious Nick Nolte this boy
started started the are the funny movies
later on but this movie was about an
actual school where they're losing
sterling the bad test score truancy what
this movie was fictional but it kind of
started the other movies that were real
and bad like teachers teacher take as
the ambassador the lives taking you
further although there were movies like
that before there was like to Sir with
love and he's teaching all these white
British kids
I saw Cliff Lee black teacher and they
loved him I'll get into it that song
sorry no I never heard I never seen that
one by the way back but then you go to
them back to the Mockingbird [ __ ] that
little rascal it was Puckle me no miss
Crabtree grouchy Huckabee with my they
were seen as his babysitters basically
they like but dude you can see the
teachers bro that guy Chris Mulligan the
actor Richard Mulligan was on soap well
good the best all right every now fool
escaped from mental hospital right and
then we walked into that school bro and
pretends to be a substitute teacher
right because there's a teacher right a
black teacher and right and she's
arguing with a white teacher right well
I got are these Latinos to they would
don't speak English and she goes I can't
teach him to read the bah bah blah right
but then that guy gave her a mental
hospital right he's a teacher there now
two egos but you're a teacher yeah we go
everybody starts talking about I can't
teach this guy I cannot teach math when
I can't even read but you're a teacher
right he keeps telling why but you're a
teacher over and over but you know they
share him up with some people need more
experience in this school oh hell yeah
that's what he hit him back with they
hit him backward but anyway pool this
fool is teaching us he's teaching about
the American Revolution
dress like Oh like George Washington bro
he's on frontiers let me dress with
everything dude here the get a fool out
without in a [ __ ] outside must get
the comic yeah bro
crazy that's a good movie like mad
reenactment hell yeah hey dude what are
you gonna say about that uh that uh you
know friend from college that one scene
about the girl well girl you were
talking about then we went somewhere
else with the French from college I went
through buying a birthday present for
herself
oh yeah she was buying a birthday
present for her style bro but man and
she finished 40 gonna keep you happy
oh the badass sure dude that's [ __ ]
shows for honey dog hell yeah dude what
I like about that show - in the end it
shows like you're the host joy one doubt
one day huh yeah no life midnight right
4 a.m. Oh what was it goes to 42
oh it was like this I've always seen
people college like those people they
all were to Harvard yeah they have cash
you know that or you know scholarship
[ __ ] that wonderful is a trust fund baby
it's the trust fund maybe or he had an
inheritance recently when she says just
cuz you have a trust fund don't know bad
for yourself peels were keys wife okay I
thought he was he had inherited a bunch
of money and he doesn't have to work
anymore but I thought I didn't know he
was trust fund babies so watching that
show was Justin Bateman man those are
supposed to have lost in yours like I
feel like every show now if you don't
think enough you know if I'm not into it
by the second episode I'm done but you
never sucked me into another ten yeah
like they shitty gonna happen to happen
to me with [ __ ] up with Tom Hardy bro
[ __ ] taboo Oh 18 episodes I was out
after two and I like sorry til 10 a lot
of [ __ ] at shows and movies that
full band I like him taboo with Tom
Hardy
that's an expensive show to flop bro
because I thought your oh [ __ ] bro damn
you need to go studio
every day I would look at shows like
we're like well the dress was costumes
bro those souls are gonna give one
chance now you can't have a show like
like Lord of the Rings bomb and you
gonna give it a second check and give a
shoulder turn a second chance because
the costume they're gonna look as good
the dragon could be make it made of
paper start slashing the budget huh
no break sometimes our show start losing
their budget bro like like you know like
it runs out right you gonna replace the
cast like we're talking last time when
they replace the cast a book about Dukes
of Hazzard was born they brought their
cousins and then they came back what's
that after it was after contract
negotiations right Mira Julie replace
Matt by Toby hey what's up toasters
what's up fool what's up fool what's up
ooh but you ever go late we have a guest
here bro yeah man it was right ladies
and gentlemen it's an honor to introduce
one of the funniest females on the
planet straight from DC please put your
hands together for Dominique whoa whoa
first we run into math he was over the
upland years ago yeah yeah was speedy
was on that show no I think berry had
some the dairy deal know that Paulson
brother Kenny berry from your dude the
Ontario it problems a lot of shows in
Chania he does that a lot
how did that do it he take girls to see
Trevino maybe all right yeah but it's a
top ten brother dog he put over the BG
rebel Gibbs you read that talk to people
man what they don't know
we're talking over the throw-in a name
like yeah but it's out throwing about
like a fake person at about that person
yeah man yeah man they got laugh a lot
right quick with a joke
here's big feat process sometimes like
people use a one word and everybody runs
with their brother you did it wrong like
my like Horizonte clever what I'm
talking about is my prerogative
right it was Google for those words for
the song but then everybody was done
using everybody no book that [ __ ] you
know it's my prerogative they hop on
that word like anything else you know
that was percolating frankly wasn't the
Nutty Professor what anybody see like we
won't start week in one weekend in and
he was dude named Daryl and it's time
for the percolator was out yeah on top
of the day and pool Tay it's always
there cheering well he didn't realize he
was backing up he perk you laid his ass
right on the floor
he kept it's time for the Perkin like Oh
Daryl percolating stand up you know
broke his teacup but that was a thought
well let's get him perk your lady yeah
there was a dance before the song right
yeah and sure her song was not even
about advance her song that wasn't even
the main then everybody start doing it
right
like you know it's don't wear bra work
with love Spanish people start using the
boat what happens I read put it but I
got percolate
no ma'am so lately everybody usually
with the process you gotta trust the
class roster process trust the process
grow well kills me and what I see
comedians like before they go out let
the put their set together take a
picture of it yeah I'm a gonna follow
the process so you see a bomb with cue
card and then you know what you know
what I mean well process is that because
you can't comment that on a person who
the man in you because they get hurt
they do because they get hurt someone
who like who's like who's 20 who's 34 to
50 years old it's gonna say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] allow ya if you write that
[ __ ] right you write to them but someone
who's 22 you hurt their feelings oh I am
more sensitive counsel in this [ __ ] like
how like you're like somebody who runs
the property right like if you were to
say like are these NBA players talking
about the process but how about
processing that big-ass l yeah but do it
doesn't even affect them like they can't
get blown to smithereens in your hand
why are you shaking his hand it's the
playoffs you you are enemies right now
what is that about everybody's all wants
to be on the nice tip not that it's bad
but you don't I'm saying like it's
overly nice yes but you're not competing
you getting blown out this man out here
shimmying on you you know me dancing
mission what are you doing
what are you doing why are you excited
why are you shaking your hands you see
that with comics though these days
comics they can't take you know the way
you guys kill each other in your
generation of comedy and you like your
bag like like da Marrero sanding you a
nice try when you come off yeah would
you lose a man right newer generation
they get hurt by that they really do but
I also think that's kind of bad because
if you're not gonna know any of that
criticism later on you're gonna [ __ ]
face some real [ __ ] you don't know what
to do from the fans but one thing about
the younger generation that's even weird
I don't know if you guys noticed this or
not
they could go up and bomb and their
peers will say good job oh they'll be
high-fiving yeah and I'm like that's not
good
give him a tag for their joke you know
when we went up in Bob and give them a
tag we went up in bomb people be like
it's all good you would leave you leave
you go home maybe like nobody wants to
shake your hand cuz they might get that
[ __ ] on them but they give them how fact
they even force their self the life and
I'm like you knew that wasn't funny why
you laughing
and they forgive they bomb they do that
Bob 20 years ago state people through
that you go to that town tell you redeem
yourself
yeah somebody from the last show yeah oh
man you really got better I show you and
you stuff with the process Oh school oh
yeah you up there oh your biggest bar my
biggest bar I'll tell you my biggest Bob
bro has to be Tacoma Washington I did
one of those shows brother every every
Hispanic comedian and maybe ethnic every
african-american goes through it
luenell called it like it's like a rite
of passage bro yeah when you get booked
by this guy Seattle don't get paid here
here
yeah oh
the show was $700 to fly to Hawaii to do
one night and then do the next night
took over Washington so you know I think
it paid for either one by the way it
didn't matter
but now but I bombed so I'm apartment in
the beginning of the show and then some
dugald up on stage and then he ran out
having a rose better but then he out
he's one year of course but I have to
follow but then you start making excuses
oh because I had to follow like
everybody has to follow the local
barbershop saying a little speech pass
out a little bartering for money all his
family's there and they don't know her
local guy who killed which is reference
this dog on a barbershop
y'all seen that picture your hometown
you always have a leg up
you always because you can talk about
some inside jokes shape with any meat
but then after a while man you come to
that town for the 10th time you're that
[ __ ] yeah your mother [ __ ]
now you go away Amy your hack from that
cherry pokey but then you go in there
and you talk about old club that's
closed down now remember the vent don't
have a clue like I've got to go in with
a celebrity like a beer we're insane I'd
be like y'all remember that [ __ ] Rock
oh boy the Bronco ball they people go
crazy see something I don't know that
you were made there I borrow hard bro at
the Bronco blow out the [ __ ] coma
Washington okay first of all I would
like the only mask in there then I bomb
harder when I said that yeah Chris Rock
was right there's black people and we
all know who you guys are flour first
Oh broke my sobriety that day I use the
air dog but yeah my bar hard those tough
in bombs I never forgot about cuz I call
somebody barbarian somebody if they
better help you what happened bro I was
not good luck
take it easy darling just a price and
not doing it you did a year away bro
what I told you girl I call it Willie
Barcena I said bow hard bro there it
goes Lydia but will it like some comics
are they switch it to therapy leaks
what's the Bobby bro
I bumped that [ __ ] at the company I
theater 1991 you know a year god damn
bro I bomb so bad at this club called um
no laughs then no like when I tell you I
bomb and I never forgot it it's the
comedy connection in Laurel Maryland I
went up there and I bombed so damn bad
and this place held like 350 people and
it was packed yeah I feel it why I'm
talking about it I bomb and I never
forgot it real excited it's a bomb so
bad they was just looking at me like get
your ass off the stage who told you you
was a comedian ain't like boo no no no
we don't want to hear it no I walked off
were you the headliner what was this
like in the middle somewhere me saying I
was just like I bombed him when I walked
off you could see like all the
comedian's will be up in this little
section right in the corner cuz the the
theater when you went up this way when I
bombed it was all looking at me like oh
wait you took a bad I know a better than
the beginning from the beginning Felipe
it wasn't good at oh I couldn't catch a
rhythm man oh I don't know [ __ ] about
you know what you want stage and you
start out like you pretty much when you
go on stage you kind of have directions
you're gonna go in when them dive racks
it's not work you got your little tricks
let me walk down this street let me walk
down this street when I'm a turn this
corner but maybe I need to reverse a
little bit you know like you're driving
the car you know they wasn't having none
of they like no not good get off I got
off but I was like I am good though like
with you when you start bombing man 20
minutes I'm a material go through one
minute bro oh hell yeah dog the heat on
your back Oh like a one-liner heat now
seven minutes friends in a 7 hour long
heat if someone please let God pushing
you out that's real you fighting it like
you did the mother you stay there the
hotter it gets you can
you can't really fight it and then but
and man I I hate when I'm Bob when I
start feeling like bombing then you go
blank man
and you guys start staring when you say
how about them Lakers that's what that's
why that's why you start looking around
the room that's why I tell people don't
bring your family to your shows in the
beginning don't bring your friends
they'll never look either same as to
that Barbie Barbie that that could bring
up a relationship man for real our
friendship you wear you know a brand you
people stop loan you money after the you
bomb like that you ain't gonna make it
homey
maybe you just try something else I am I
did that I made that mistake though I
bought my own and everything to another
show at this little club one good and
I've never invited her since Tuesday I
want to come to one of the shows and I
just felt like maybe you did it to me
better after that maybe it was you I was
like all right I'm invites all right
Bobby feels like um drugs I don't think
for right again for me will be like I
don't know man be like to watch someone
you love so much so much get you having
sex with like your friends one at a time
bro and looking at what it is it's okay
you trying to stop her bro but you can
and then everybody swing then your
friends are going it's cool it's cool
it'll be alright if you don't like it
like that it's gonna be alright
right right and she's telling you I'm
fine I'm fine but you're like hurting
inside
you know but that's the way bombing
nears because all those people are gonna
tell you it's gonna be alright I'm fine
but you know it's not gonna be fine how
do you recover from that and get strong
enough to come back again I don't know
that's what I could never do it again
it's you know you're gonna be a
different kind of human be to accept
failure over and over at that cuz yeah
cuz I'd better there hurts here we all
try to do it again yes it's almost like
you know how they say crackheads they
always say see what if ya ever chasing
with chasing and we chasing new you
laugh we chase I should feel good little
of I'm telling you when you got them
that big laughs going there's no other
feeling in the world so we always chase
and we always start right in that zone
oh give me the light
they're giving you the life they giving
you tonight you better believe when I
see you rocking around you going update
get her off yes always like I think this
is just like you always chasing you do
but it is uh just hurtful Hart was up
there but it is just like you're just
you you keep chasing and you it cause
it's disappointment like Felipe say it I
have to disappointment
so if you started as an open mic or and
you kept bombing I'm not a comedian but
okay and you can't Bobby and you never
got the laugh there you probably would
drop off sooner than the others right if
you get a couple laughs that's that
taste yeah you wanting to come back you
open mic and you're not getting any
laughs you can do nothing you're more
likely to stop me probably you probably
should cuz even open my car when you got
it you won't get some laughs something
but but yeah stuff maybe you get nothing
if you get nothing maybe it's not a good
idea
yeah I shouldn't be up there man no but
I've seen people who were not funny who
are just stupidly not funny to the
audience later on that seems to be that
it's making me [ __ ] laugh out loud
because it just grows on you again you
realize okay this was a stupid idea
just the comic no it's a stupid act just
think it's really good what's your with
Bob would you me that's like cutting
getting jumped and you have your arms
and legs tied behind your back you can't
fight back just keep coming at man not
to be motionless physically it's very
emotional thing man but you know we'll
cry me trans beat beat up over and over
about but the pains gonna go away and
I'm gonna get beat up again but it's
that it was more than a heartbroken to
me man
yeah and to be a heartbroken how do you
- my friends have my wife stay with my
wife and my girlfriend I'll be
heartbroken or heartbroken for me it was
I'm gonna jump I haven't beat up and you
know I walked away from that but nah man
stays with you but you know what's
hurtful - I don't know if you guys feel
this way is when you as the years pass
and you got pretty consistent we're
getting laughs and pretty much you know
at this point okay at this point I'm a
rip I'm pretty decent I'm pretty good at
this and then one of those days happened
when you don't give it don't never go
you know it's not as bad as when you Bom
Bom but you know okay I was just alright
you know those hurt me - those are more
hurtful because you're already in the
professional step yeah you know but even
though sometimes I hear the audience one
way but you'll say man I didn't think
they laughed at anything or I didn't
think I'd feel like you won't feel like
you did very well but it was a fun it
was fun I think you feel that you'll be
doing it for a long time like you're
critiquing yourself I guess more harshly
yeah Lenny my father did not get them in
the middle
right one little egg but we're the last
time you say your father like this was a
bomb mean like what sure you think it
was Rodrigo whatever you said way well
no we're not giving up to nobody and you
were there too what did he give it up to
you the last one buddy well could you
hold ease huh oh yeah weird dude cuz
wild coyotes you didn't get a chance if
you weren't rocking it right away that's
that's what's funny a lot of people
don't get that now you get a chance now
to go up on stage that's true yeah a lot
of cheer oh dude I want you to do good
yeah there's like I don't want to cycle
before it was like [ __ ] you
gotta make me laugh yeah yeah like a
somebody will yell out don't give up
while I'm up there I'll give up that
cheer me on
but people get that nowadays you're
right I'm okay move on Oh be back they
will just boo get off oh dude it was
though they had no time for that and
then you're you know they had you you
were going up until like an in-between
solid professionals too so yeah the
crowd can kind of tell ya tell more
about our about how about the Lakers
things Oh cuz I was at this place that
uh cuz I bombed this that was that was a
place in Moreno Valley cheers cooking
used to do that place just a top five
rooms oh yeah well that's why I didn't
know any better I didn't know where to
go I got a rule that if a person I
started at The Comedy Store if I would
equip you know your friend like hats off
to rooms but different rooms yard not
that this is easy but it's just like
different but so I'm on stage and was a
brother on stage and [ __ ] and you know
he was doing good all right but then
[ __ ] it wasn't happening
boys I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
and that's when that Ludacris song was
on move like a big old black lady in the
back and then she's all oh how about
them Lakers oh yeah my [ __ ] all right so
he goes down and you know cookie over
there trying to cheer
then blow that [ __ ] yes would you
suppose I go in there trying to hit him
and hit him and with him and some bigger
brother in the back come on man get your
ass out here with those all that Jordan
looking like a broke-ass Paul Rodriguez
battled that a little 10 minutes through
but it was like you know not as bad as
the other dude but I was still kind of
in that real more like nobody brought it
back to I was opposed right was there
any good heckler stories yeah bro uh-huh
who the devil the heckle but I know the
guy that guy was like Peter Berg eyes
glasses oh dude
what's Turner's comedian man he said
what the [ __ ] died he [ __ ] Luther
glasses you can see the [ __ ] future
of the [ __ ] glasses guy said you
don't have one but you got a no wait
that go the glasses so he proposed a
picked on his old life ones he was ready
and you gotta know when a heckler ready
though some comedians don't know when
they ready just fo yo a wile coyote said
what happened to you and people come up
and shake your hand afterward that was
fun they were heckling there were little
stars - yeah like at bar stars a regular
bar club the people that go every week
and they heckle every week and they
shake you're right they shake your hands
into the show you were man like the way
I help I wouldn't have to look at what's
up to you after you [ __ ] him up you
didn't do half your act
nobody got to see your act are they tell
you is clown here clown him clown a town
you were done hey that's the way I
helped you out
want to help me out man we'll find a
promoter
sometimes I'll tell it to like I don't
want to do this to you babe cuz I'm a
talking I'm adding mamas and daddies and
all that I say so do you want me I don't
want to do it I'm giving you opportunity
oh okay how about ones [ __ ]
heckle and you [ __ ] heckle the [ __ ]
out of and they try to get all violent
on your ass yes they made now you'll
know me hey dog I'm ready to set up in
here take it huh hell naw but they
started me how you gonna start something
can't take it why you started the day
eat your chicken wings drink your hand
on the rocks and shut up but it is iPod
- no that wasn't your wife but Terrell
jingle because I do Dusty Rhodes right
Ric Flair I was always especially at the
wild coyotes I was like muhfuckas talk
[ __ ] and the students [ __ ] somebody
[ __ ] found it was just like the
scatter go always hear these
[ __ ] were laughing with me now
they're all there sitting with the
victim like I also don't like when you
get booked by this promoter mhm and then
the promoter has a little table for his
friends and that's it was actually
privileged table but not but I never get
another gift enough with enough with
them Dania do gar shows back in the day
do guy has some serious shows back in
the day shout out to do god somebody we
were talking about people were people
back here in our Lee will talk about his
show that being so loud and so bad they
ruin power to me now man he shows he pay
you though yeah he paying you down but
to short it is boy be hacked into the
whole show
what about you I like when the heck live
when you get the hex in the whole table
they laughing at his ass they can't take
it no more first they all had this
united stance and after where they just
dropped a hey I see a scene and your
friends like your family laughing at
your now so it's an imminent problem you
need to shut up me like like I've given
people who heck with me nicknames to
this day that nickname lives Wow that
they call that [ __ ] that Wow
when I go back again hey there goes my
friend what's his name but don't even
know that I use the same joke on that
[Laughter]
nationwide now those another tweet I had
this week bro was weak enough topics
then amusing has gotten so bad that I
cannot wait for the next nationwide
commercial come out nationwide good
singers bro yeah yeah [ __ ] up to do
the nationwide commercial I don't know
what the hell he is
I'm from Empire no got you like you know
that elbow knee way like that an album
but this guy [ __ ] yodeling has a
[ __ ] motel that no malbim already
million followers
[Music]
we live in a nicer world where it's
crazy we live in a nicer world because a
little kid like that in my generation
he'll be he'll be bully to the whole
life who never will close the game they
would take that guitar and beat his ass
with it like who did that kid when I got
to school and they want to show that
those kid in the news on the [ __ ]
channel 7 Eyewitness News
Ashley Devine whenever I see their buyer
is talking about yeah a little kid
singing like a little quick singing in
Walmart this morning
and they show up they know who the kid
go back to school with boots boots
we would bag on Mexican I'm Mexican we
were back on Mexican foods that came to
school with boots on dog anything just
ridiculous that goes viral now they were
[ __ ] you up
Oh pretty much a little kid charlie bit
my finger
welcome to somebody a hidden affair with
a pie now bro you can't you can do
anything now
I don't like those like the I feel him
saying the people can't sing anymore I
don't even know why that's accepted like
wow wow mediocrity celebrated though all
the time all the time what is that a
bomb because now the music companies are
in control because now they know they
can just create a star you know you can
like Nicki Minaj a star you can like
ariana grande who are all these new like
manufactured people but even the
rapper's too like you just say okay
we're gonna dress you up like this we're
gonna partner you with these people
we're gonna you know they just see money
and they go okay okay they're not but
not any good music they're just a
creation for the marketing it's all
instant to Frank Zappa say like when it
when it when it when it when we ruin
music and it was well it was an older
guy right an old guy right who who gave
this guy this wild guy that was thinking
it with a guitar you know rock n roll
music he saw him in a bar
this old guy said who gave that guy a
chance and that guy sold millions on
records
then the old guy said I'm gonna get more
guys like that how am I gonna find one
guy like that so they hired a guy some
of that guy's age to go find more guys
who look like that guy everybody started
following the same routine doing that
[ __ ] today
yeah the same way people are so afraid
to lose their don't see what it took but
it took an old guy
a real old guy but if the young guy we
hire that's gonna hire the same type of
people without getting the music be
different and new they're gonna just
look for that same thing to make another
hit another hit and then instant
starters go there and pop them out three
three million records real quick and
they're [ __ ] forgotten that's the
process recycling that [ __ ] give you
longevity in Americans were addicted in
newness we'd like new [ __ ] quick Madison
if it's good or not yeah just that one
song like like Ke$ha okay so so I knew I
know Ke$ha the best friend her childhood
friend that she grew up with they both
lived out here I was waiting tables with
her friend Ke$ha was like she'd show up
every once in a while but she wasn't
Ke$ha yet she was just kissa
okay her real name is Ke$ha but anyway
yeah so she shows up to like our karaoke
nights and stuff but she's underage she
snuck in all the time without an ID and
um but she'd hang out and then she would
go up and do karaoke and she was
horrible
like horrible like beyond like you can
tell this person can't even carry a tune
right and she would talk about she just
got back from Japan and touring all I
know is you hang out with us sometimes
in your underage like that's all I know
about you and then all of a sudden boom
she's on Flo Rida's song and I and she
was singing on that what is it you
turned me right round baby right round
that's her on that song that was her
first kind of transition into American
pop music like that that scene and then
she got her own record deal but it was
all creation you know they like she's a
certain personality but they just they
put they dressed her they planned all
that marketing plan this is how we're
gonna do the music and you know it's and
then inside there's this person there
and it's amazing it's magic you don't
even have to be like I hate somebody
tell me well you know you in comedy you
don't really have to be funny anymore
it's more marketing okay so really you
don't have to be funny anymore so what
is the purpose of comedy if you don't
have to be funny anymore
but we see that that's true though no
people will show up with it buy beer
though oh yeah it's weird but the thing
is they're categorizing comedy
differently like you and you're seeing
but they're seeing like vine which
doesn't exist anymore or like YouTube or
Instagram five minute videos one minute
videos you know you have that crazy
friend dancers everywhere and they take
already-existing jokes and just make it
into a video and then boom they're a
sensation tell you anybody flat tummy
and decent boobs and you're [ __ ] 23
to 26 years old you could put up any
video and say yeah that you have that
crazy friend doesn't everywhere yeah and
she starts working and showing her but
then at the mall and Vons a fool for
less raus raus blows up my blouse if I
do it bro nobody me here that won't
friend anywhere any chicks showing any
type of body's gonna have over like cars
no matter what a media ad that comedic
little element to it have that little
[ __ ] - it's a stand-up comedy's to a
king though you can see happily over
there I love comedy it's still hard to
do oh yeah you could take that person
was 7 million views and go up on stage
and do comedy and he didn't do a comedy
I I witnessed that happen at 11:30
o'clock show this YouTube star so let
the whole room how much time do they do
nothing the whole show without two-hour
meeting greeting yeah 20 minutes of
being onstage doing something that's the
total show I walk around with uh with a
little horse you know in the broom the
broom horse
like Connie and there were $45 tickets
to get in and they were our little girl
they were brought there with a bullet by
their parents and the parents were duped
the dad was asking like what did I pay
for yeah what'd you pay for your dad for
another scream for an hour and by burch
he walked out of there with $45 sold-out
show at 11:30 in the morning Orlando
improv in the morning and so like around
$5,500 merch see you guys later I'm 21
years old
whoa welcome to America's finest browser
12 14 year old daughter I'm 21 years old
[ __ ] suck it use a pistol or another
how do you like that we stirred yeah
your dad waited for trouble but I'm
lucky he suckered a unicorn broom dig
right now there were twins by the way
shout out to twins disgusted this guy
said two dollars worth of YouthWorks
bucks 20 bucks were so full twins with a
V this guy
oh that's he right there
yeah bro making a killing huh he puts
his dad on something puts his dad right
there look it's two middle-eastern guys
and the killing it bro
killing it sugar videos are short of his
videos and a billion views and if you
notice most of the sensations on the
internet and you in Instagram and all
that day yeah that's other thing to you
so youth in America you don't sell old
muhfuckas unless you're prolific like
Anthony Bourdain or something seriously
you have to have something really deep
to say is gonna mesmerize much Oh
my grandfather watch with you I can't
play the song
but it wasn't that one of the sensations
BAM look for some areas arms the bucket
whoof man over here
[ __ ] Teen Wolf right here tween lama
tsong I see a beer Navi in your hometown
next weeks and your daughter or
reselling church for $35 and I love you
singing about Lama
I don't know but when you think about
all the stuff they do on here you almost
have to be young oh yeah understand that
[ __ ] ya ain't to even do it imagine
that something what he was just doing it
messed a cake oh you sweetie you come
home and watch it it's got your dad
doing that going mom you got about that
but and then what's funny about all this
[ __ ] then you got the thousands of
copycats to do with these [ __ ]
yeah at that little lower number level
yeah it's horrible it is how I work
though to stay on your phone all day
long and make these videos it it's do
you have to be good girl I mention it
with your girlfriend that one friend
that dances everywhere yeah the quality
of the video is tip-top
let's go get Rizal put his qualities a
little better than little treat you hear
the train going by mama cook in the
kitchen if I start with neat mess so
would you get started at DC started in
DC I'm from DC but I did work a lot in
Baltimore cuz it's only 30 minutes away
yeah timonium you come on simonia I'm
gonna tell you we used to go there every
year for a church fair they had a fair
up in timonium every year my grandmother
with fried chicken make potato salads
and stuff like that it's like a bus trip
but I did start DC and then from DC I
went to New York and then I landed out
here it's been like what now 23 years
now yeah I went to DC a couple of times
with um max Amini I did the Bethesda
theater yeah fall church Falls Church
church yeah we did our love only to
draft order to drive house easy improv
yeah the State Theatre - yeah they do a
friend of mine doesn't once a month
they're at the Bethesda Jazz Club that's
off the chain in DC so he doesn't want
someone there
he wants me to do it by using when I go
out through the theater so I can't do
the club right now cuz I do the theater
you would never didn't show - you never
do a big ass show bro Tracy Morgan's
feisty first show it was his friend shot
from his accident yes yeah it was Tracy
for your first joke yeah it was hosted
he was hosting that show gentleman - he
was young gentleman and we went out
there but he's so comical right you know
he's in this crash but the way he did
you see him for me by the way he act
like he'll be back
somebody say what's up Tracy yeah you
like yo who's that you know I can't see
you I went blind I was in a coma yo you
like why are you saying this yeah nobody
wants to laugh at this this is very sick
yo you know I can't see you like he was
walking up the stage he gonna stop right
cuz I saw before him at Caroline's in
New York he gave her first daughter he
did at Caroline's he really did Oh what
happened because I was telling the
process yeah okay so hey I trusted the
process were you percolate what
regulators you leave me but I was
trusting the process right I couldn't
get in that Club right it's Caroline's
on Broadway
huge Club and he start bringing me there
to open for him
I met Tracy in New York when he used to
wear the propeller hat and I went there
one time and I had seen him on some
other shows that some of my friends were
on but I wasn't on the show but out the
after party and everything and he saw me
work somewhere so we were friends from
there and I got in that Club he put me
on that um at Caroline's and after that
I was able to work that Club get
sponsors that clothing but gonna call
you for spy yeah yeah you know what I
mean
and so we've been friends with me he put
me in this independent movie called 30
years to life that he was doing he put
me in that movie I've been on the road
with him you know and all that kind of
stuff
well I'll give her her first time I saw
Dominique as my horrible Tracy Lucas
here outside I can't really do a good
representation if I see someone doing
really good yeah yeah we got you know
with you he's so funny time the story he
walked up the stairs and this one we
where well said we where Madison Square
Garden a top of the world stop killing
it okay like the legend look together
wound up first before me the other shoe
that will attempt by monkey yeah what
was it over there
yeah he was on your podcast with me Tony
when you look to any like um you hear a
comment from the East Coast talk there
was the young man it was me and Tony
woods there's alright who is this guy
and I finally meet him yeah so we went
to UM so we did that on Madison Square
God he walking up the stairs right and I
hadn't seen him in a while right just a
white hey dressed in white so I he was
walking upstairs and I could hear
something like a little like a little
pop right you gonna stop he's like yo
heard that it's gonna do that [ __ ] for
the rest of my life all [ __ ] up yo who
says that but but he really helped me
I've been blessed knowing this in his
business I had a lot of people that took
me on the road with them so that's a
blessing that's how I feel somehow yes
um I took care of me somehow you know
I've been on the road with my cabs I've
been on the road we know lavell Crawford
been on the road with Tracy Morgan
and so when I were going to rode with
those people I'm an easy act to work
with you know some people difficult for
no reason you know my company how much I
do an extra to nobody gonna notice the
process of time the process of time I
get there on time you know I do my time
when I get my light I'm like okay I'm
gonna start wrapping it up and put that
that made the people the promoters like
me that made me familiar with the clubs
so it really really owe it all help me
you know hell yeah would you do Def Jam
I did that thing when they did it out
here and wasn't that like early 2001
Mike Epps host if not that original one
well we're to do with Corey Holcomb um
the original Def Jam I think no I was on
the Chris Rock one the rhythm Devlin was
Chris Rock yeah yeah he was host a dude
named Ronnie long from Philly
Ronnie long Ronnie long Rudy rush Rudy
rush myself TV appearance but I think
when I did some time maybe like in the
meet late nineties making your New York
tell people who shook it how's it look
at that time except that one joke about
do you know how to row yeah do you know
how to roll absolutely I do now
[ __ ] I roll with know how to
rock you know some a road for cyclists
to dominate look like she wrote fat
below each other how it is absolutely so
that um you know so then I start and
then we're really really um so I went on
the road with those people I was able to
go by myself when I started doing on Tom
Joyner oh that's when you were certain
headlining do your own thing yes because
he's syndicated so with that syndication
I was doing this all I was doing
segments like three times a week
awesome I come on do a segment and he
just told me a story and I'm like Oh Tom
and did I just go into these funny rants
about the story well anyway to do was
like
well I'm gonna try you on a couple of
dates at the club and he knew them nine
million listeners there Tom hey every
morning they came through the club I was
like oh okay
so that's kind of how that works I'm
just grinding it out oh yeah and while
black Jesus that's coming over coming
we already so long hiatus it was we have
it in the can so we just grateful baby
directed boy how come my baby dead on
the show to promote it
yes think it's on the show so I'm doing
black Jesus I'm working on the stand-up
show I'm trying to figure out where to
shoot it so I'm working on this paying
down you want to view only Patricia
O'Neill stories I do
that is crazy I love trees so we did
this Def Jam I don't know if you all
heard of yeah in London no we went on
yeah we went on to Ananda Patrice O'Neal
my realtor this a tool okay we did some
cities in London but Patrice O'Neal was
the Tony Roberts Capone was I can't
think of but for Treece Dickie capris
brother now I can see Patrice his face
so vividly he ate a Kiwi Kiwi but he
peeled of [ __ ] the van that we ride
though right Russell Simmons was there
staying later so we riding this van I
came on a branded for truthers on the
van sitting like this with tears what
happened he's a star Bulger cuz he ate
the whole key we didn't mean pill it I
don't know why he I thought if you eat
should've known how to eat a Kiwi if
you're gonna eat Kiwi most people do put
trees
like we laugh to him so hard for trees
like y'all you need to go to doctor your
eyes popping out of your heat kid stands
up and said quit telling me [ __ ] they're
comedians really like his eyes bulging
but the biggest thing about for trees
that he helped me with we were talking
about joke thieves and he was like we
tell my joke these like I don't even
worry about it I just kind of try to
move past them and he was like he said
we don't really have to worry about it I
said Wow people still joke he said cuz
you your jokes are so much of who you
are he said it's gonna be hard for them
to rip you off I was like okay and I had
people drop jewels on me the whole time
and they still do when I see comics and
stuff they still drop drew so I didn't
have some experiences in in a lot of
places with some dope comics yeah man
that's what Madison Square Garden the
biggest show ever been on that show it's
always helped me get more shows yeah cuz
I'm you killed it cuz I sold it Tracy
Morgan now he met on my name going up
yeah you really like ten times he's
practicing in the back telling me about
him in a car accident oh my god like
this
yo who is it you know I wasn't a coma
right I feel nothing smoke yours you got
me something yeah rolling papers decided
to roll with yes mine thank you thank
you gonna rob left those here he's walks
like Pigpen a lot of stuff just flies
around
what table fool man what was that um
well the light was Tracy Morgan man with
anything you drinking on him sorry
all the like work he was Tracy Morgan
were you with him when you're sober or
drunk I was with him but we were
partying Omaha yeah I was with him but
at the height of SNL right yes now I
used to hang out with him men at the
height of SML and we would go through
the clubs and at that time I drank I
don't drink anymore but at that time I
drank so we're get to the club right and
you know you can know where you already
concealed when he bought the cut-up
you'd be like oh we like this no Alice
oh let me tell you about Caroline's you
want to hear about that
you're the 20 rocker huh Tony will be on
the shows me wheel savants Tony rock we
drinking long okay damn right we
drinking Long Island iced teas dude and
we got three shows so we get there
before the show and we didn't drag you I
mean they bring a more diverse relaxed
yeah the host you know I'm only doing
ten minutes yeah what I'm saying so
strong ten because I'm trusting the
process nothing like being a being a
packed show bro big headline it was nice
as hell and you drink you lose your top
of the world bro to the side in the
bathroom trying to pick up they bring
your food so right yo why the [ __ ]
you're bringing yo one iced tea at a
time yo keep putting that [ __ ] yo so
they bring them and we drink and we
drink it where the night pass and or we
drink it so I already knew the first
show I made the second show I was up
there I was like I'm drunk as [ __ ] so
I'm up there talking through the peep
I'm like oh yeah
they laugh it but I'm struggling right
cuz Hale last show all of us shit-faced
drunk
well Tracy was so drunk he fell off the
stage you know how Caroline's the earth
right then look hurtin
if you step back too far on that curtain
you gonna come off the stage he was back
there like this they had to pick a
puppet we had to have a meeting with the
management when we got there the next
day the next day was sold out - yes the
next day was sold out but we were so
drunk so I hung with him and his
drinking days we went to one club and
you can always tell when he's gonna
start a trip we see a big gym that was
his driver when he take his shirt off oh
oh we get a music is going back and for
my feet here's an old rapper with him
huh oh no Tracy Morgan I was like an
older rapper hanging out with him
yes sometime he could but it just
depending on who he had hanging with he
drive he keep dancing me and then we
walk in right and people like Joe Tracy
yo Tracy
yo Tracy so I didn't after we get drunk
we leaving out right so just one dude
what up Tracy he was like what why did
he grab the man's drink
oh he saying it just turned to cross the
club let's go drunk there people would
call me maybe like oh did you see your
boy on the front page of the New York
thumb the Daily News seems like every
week back there yeah carrying him out
the club Amy got say on me one night he
gonna say
i'ma Drive you home no you're a saint
you can't drive no way he's like oh are
you drunk like that I got this we we we
have sometimes 100 thing about 20 rock
we're doing a show and he was telling me
in the net word about that same that
you're talking about and then he goes
the rock was day yeah and then exactly
the way you said it man and he will say
nah man and then but and then but the
Tory rock is he he said in a story is
like you are like a concerned comedian
like nah man thinks him call me thank
you son they kept coming he said he
lined them all up and he was he down to
one by one they kept coming and he said
they was on stage and he started arguing
somebody to frontally man who likes to
look up my sister break that somebody
gave her joy and he lit it took big hit
in every past our stage he fell back
there into the current so I'm like this
I'm like you have no solo weekend right
yeah we would just start in the weekend
so I I mean I'm in the back of the time
right I'm not even in the showroom I'm
in the back I'm like I didn't drink too
much liquor now this is bad like yo come
out there
Traci fell out I get around the corner
to you know write out the little
dressing room they picking him up out
the back I was like oh there's Pat Pat's
house he drunk his hail yeah he didn't
finish the show but I have the meeting
three tickets come on man well you went
home with a Tracy Morgan story the Tracy
he held the chain though Felipe Italian
no doubt he's calmer now he's calmer no
very sweet guy a very reserved we're
Manhattan
I had no we bro I don't know where
Darnell with Darnell Rollins yeah I know
don't know why me hooked it up bro like
he give it a lot yeah see the night
hell yeah I hate a podcast man for me
baby at the Fargo I'm doing my pockets
were you doing
hell yeah I do cuz everybody killed it
everybody killed it
Felipe crushed it I wasn't out there but
I could just hear the laughs I was like
in the back I fell when you alright
like see it at this point I can talk
about my shoe strange man but the whole
day the hotel dude or whatever I said or
no nervous as hell bro you were no doing
katene yeah cuz I was doing like a new
it'll be like like Tracy Morgan the Big
Shot DeRay Davis it was a big seller
with no showed you came don't be bombing
yeah I was amazing though everybody
stood through the light yeah Lucy ever
think about these shows about who's
gonna go over because I think about the
Laugh Factory or the Comedy Store that
should have been doing accomplished or
improv
ain't no way you would have been here to
be home at like 4:00 in the morning yeah
like biggest o any sure you been through
it well you said man we're gonna go home
late where the headliner was up or you
you know the show was gonna run late
like in those theater shows like I know
in the theater game that they always
tell us you gotta stick to your time
because once you they got a bit that
overtime onion Union stuff it starts
going in there pocketing and once there
happens
they gonna blame you I was on one too
where they wanted to charge the artist
yeah they do that yeah they'll do that
they want to charge the odd things like
and I can hear the artist yelling you
know when you go settle up they were
arguing like you went over we need you
to pay for this comes out of the
expenses before they give the profit but
usually I already had that problem
Felipe because if when I'm on winning
big shells in the headliner goes up
pretty much I like dip off you know
that's why the Nell said she said doing
15 I get off comedy clothes a lot of
comedy
don't even care man no no you're talking
my like on those workout nights in
Prague lately
get him in Prague they don't care like
they're also home yeah you know but
sometimes shows seem like thanks oh and
a half yeah they're more relaxed cuz
they're home like I don't want to be in
my house but I think they should run it
the same way I hit it off dude I think
the more professional ones do the ones
you know who already have something
going on they do but I feel like some of
the other ones who are trying to it
always reminds me of that Doug Williams
thing Doug Williams Jamie Foxx back and
forth because those kind of people who
are at at a different level than the
headliners you know those people are the
ones who are gonna run the light they
want to be seen more they want people to
see their whole act to see how great I
am next to this headliner you know what
I mean on the same stage but just do it
in a quick time yeah they're chasing
they're trying to find that perfect
laugh - you know like just like you know
what I was buying at the end I don't
have a somebody just say deuces someone
we just can't find that laughs so the
good name their name - true comedy they
can't trust the process either so when
your child abroad process lists upcoming
shows people all right improv this week
May 24 through 27 Miami Saturday's
already sold out Miami May 31st at Magic
City casino I'm headlining the ultimate
money ultimate Miami comedian
competition I'll be wrestling ten
comedians to championship of the world
we're not in the contest headlining
after the contest is over for an hour
I'm coming to Schomburg Illinois
somebody somewhere they call the Chi
cago improv but not really in Chicago
with a somber I mean that with Tracy
Morgan actually it's forever it but but
no but they still to come from Chicago
because they know they all have
Club like that so they come in so made
15 through 17 Schaumburg we then invited
my under we have time to go but we
didn't buy it to go to the White Sox
game and get a tour of although what the
chicago game' ok also el paso san
antonio orlando coming up in June
checkoff flipping world.com slash tour
because I'm adding new dates all the
time and that's because I'm blessed and
trust the process and also you have this
community is held how do we mean you got
what they always got to put that in me
he no makeshift calm you got the real
deal lady Thank You June the 1st through
the 3rd the Baltimore comedy factory
during the 7th through the 9th I'll beat
the in Charlotte at the comedy zone in
Charlotte June the 16th through the 18th
out being Jacksonville that the comedies
on me Jacksonville June the 23rd I'll be
at the Orleans Arena in Vegas and June
24th I'll be if the Rema Theatre in
Houston Texas June corner yeah the
podcast is called the funniest here with
Dominique and Friends you'll be going on
for a while right we just started but
they did that dude we didn't work it
didn't work out hey this didn't work out
like we just we not business partners so
the funny is here yeah the funniest here
with Dominique and friends and I want
you guys all y'all to come on in a
comedy pop-up Network yeah a comedy
pop-up Network the funny is here with
dominic and Francis oh yeah
your Instagram I do my Instagram is
Dominique comma die I was trying to be
slick it's fuzzy double I was but as
somebody told me you not know how a lot
of bookworms I was like Dominique comedy
it's like no that's coma die like ah so
it's Dominique Co M EDI that's Instagram
that's Twitter and on Facebook is for
but comedian do anybody my nephew tell
me Facebook he say they don't do
Facebook I was like we thought Facebook
though yeah the audience is different
and they're more sensitive and they are
own madly sensitive and they a lot of
political views oh my state come on on
Facebook like that he's only 18 right so
folks home it's all snapchat Instagram
yes pretty much down they don't even use
Twitter these days those guys no they
don't they like for them right they're
into like 6 second movies do you know
this guy right there here from DC yeah I
met this guy I met this guy I met this
guy looks like Tookie Williams his name
there was no little address on that book
his name is Larry Larry he's from DC and
you know my name is Larry Larry
anyway nobody be Velos jokes in
Riverside at the Fox that's Tuesday June
12th tickets at the door
$10 brought to you by a division on
gallery enclose McCord hola myself I'm a
podcaster going on yeah yeah man
episode 39 is up check it out please the
Mercer Yemen new newer newer yeah man a
t-shirt new merch and a new what's up
oh yeah we got them in Welsh guy to rag
over the old guy yeah I'm start to
allege the larger that food or Bibles
guy the one school together they do good
work and they're great they're a little
more expensive and they do that work
like they'll tell you in here two weeks
they'll give you two weeks okay yeah no
guy that you turn in two weeks that
should be rate a month guys are not
part-timers I knew right away I got
swamped they by lowrider magazine well
this guy right there he wrote a I'm
Dominique I mean we were eating at some
restaurant right in the neck in like the
like DC bad DC started to look good
neighborhood like in between and this
guy was a sausage I was at the phone
talking on the phone right there was why
would you approach him what you approach
him and actually the he would not hear
on the phone talk it's on the pay phone
and the pay for talking like that
clarify it was a pay phone they still
gonna stop I stopped then and then he
hung up he was praying but you're
praying on the phone Wow he was praying
to God on the phone but he was selling
his own book as it's what I gotta buy it
10 bucks 10 bucks we don't bully the
whole book was called it was I'm hotter
how to grab a man and make him your
husband it was basically how to get a
man to do anything for you or give you
and yeah whatever
whole process about how to get it that's
for the ladies
I read it cover to cover I read a manual
cover to cover
he said like sometimes your man his
favorite dish might be mac and cheese so
what you got is Chinese food so what you
had a run run out to his favorite
restaurant that makes its food and you
bring that photo to your house when you
get to your house you grab all your pots
you put on some nice dishes you put some
nice dishes some candles like you made
it and then you get two pots and you
feel them up with water you boil them so
the water starts boiling and then you
get your food for the restaurant you
pour in those pots and when he gets home
and they look and smell like you could
we into deception now you want to
prospect yeah that's a massage a
shoulder rub tell him how what a great
man and provider he is like rub his feet
like stuff and after some good
lovemaking then you just say how about I
could use really use a nice car oh those
are the people who do that shirts
okay sure to Paul my little brother all
right
well he's he's the other guys and they
prank slow dog you got a float with me
what fool whoa you're all here no not
living our life full-time I do I'm not
moving
like people always like oh well they'll
have earthquakes okay well it was one in
DC - and it was one in Maryland so
everybody everybody's having them now so
I just don't I don't like the four
seasons really anymore and like people
always like well what is it with living
out there he's got a hard to explain you
have to move here find oh I just don't
want to be born I like living out here
better than living on the east coast
like I'm going Saturday I'm going to UM
you know I'm going to DC Saturday they
barbecuing and
when a holiday but I'm going there but I
don't want to live there anymore I like
never know he I like the Sun you know
I'm from the valley now nobody else is
however people move back to their
hometown or they quit Carmody or
whatever they did to go back or they
could you see they let our late motors
or now or let our late to move to Texas
but then they write up their post or I
couldn't handle that drama or they see
exactly or they can't say high rank or
they say I can't handle that the drama
between Latino comedians or if it's a
black of me I can't drama all that drama
with urban comedians like because to me
like people always say they and I know
what he's talking about
they got too much drama and I'm like
what's wrong with drama isn't it it's
like my thing is you always wherever you
go you gonna find kindred spirits matter
what you know comedians that I'm trying
their whole heart or the Mexican
American comedians which are the whole
lives
she just crossed over to white people so
bad like do I write these these perfect
gems that you're gonna cross over and
kill it every white bar ain't no and
then and they're gonna love you and then
and then they realize that that [ __ ]
doesn't really work you know really
where their work their excuse now is
this I never hung out with a Latino
comedian because there's too much drama
in Latino community I want to because I
don't want to be considered a Latino
comedian bro you're Latino I'm gonna
[ __ ] where you go gonna be a [ __ ]
Mexican community where the [ __ ] wah
well I could I could get I could man and
conquer the world the first year things
all right Mexico media Philippe aphorism
accepted are you this Mexican yeah I
live they pay my bills thank you very
much and you suppose accepted but they
always talk about the drama no way
stalking I'm always like I don't I never
see it because the people that I met
with I mesh with I don't care who you
are black white Latino a week if we hit
it all
we hit it all I don't do drama song in
this person and that person and I did
never be like what Felipe saying and I
think that helps your longevity to all
this trying to be somebody else you are
who you are and that's the best formula
in comedy who are you who you are who
you are like I used to have friends and
you start we say I'm they told me to
write my TV set I said what the [ __ ] is
a TV set they couldn't explain you know
write your TV show and put it in jokes
what I was like over writing the show
first yeah I the stand effect and they
all do it they'd be like you're not
gonna do it they like you always going
against the grain when it works for you
I'm gonna do it you know work yet I
remember and this community come up to
me right before I went now because it
philippic and I knew what they were
supposed to go up like two people behind
me or behind me I don't know when can
you look man can I go before you man
I'm trying out my Tonight Show set right
go ahead right but but no biggie back he
just basically was saying I can't follow
you that's pretty much where you become
at you tonight show up right here so
whack they're so not funny in it cross
over and if you sit man if somebody tell
you write this TV show set and you
sitting there with this pin trying to
write this TV so show said you not trust
in the process process back backwards
you know you it's not organic you taking
that you you taking that organic part
out of it and then I would go see their
sad things like I'm doing my TV show
show show set come on see me I'm coming
they get up there it's horrible you
might as where did your record show and
said that's my TV show said that's the
way I did it div mighty we do this TV
say well maybe you don't get my show but
this is my show I did my TV set want
someone about TV when I stay with the TV
[Laughter]
like when they turn it make it sound
like your higher mind you would actually
like work on my comedy central set
industry it's just a shame say we were
ten years older yeah but that's the
interest in the industry talk but if you
own that that interested song it'll mess
your hair up
they will square do a lot of comedic so
thrown off like I think I write blogs I
ain't complaining about the business but
they don't even have a [ __ ] they
never gave me work
one of the things I had decided long ago
and I've known is to happen the comics
in this business because of the way this
business is you got to decide that
you're not gonna let what's going on in
this business kill you cuz it will strip
you down every tear your health down and
all those type of things and I know
dudes that that happened to that the
reality of what you're dealing with you
gotta trust the process and enjoy the
journey
stick to your craft paint grinding can I
quote you domine yes keep keep grinding
and know that you know what I got the
goods I'm gonna get where I'm going
yeah man but out cuz all that other
stuff you'll be crazy listening to cuz
the industry they just make up stuff to
just keep you holding on okay do you do
you do you uh do you do your TV she'll
stand do my so far process right what
you call to do your own do the Tonight
Show Center for me if whatever said I do
long as I ain't cussing if it's funny I
should be to get on The Tonight Show
ampion people like believing in one way
and then quit it I realized that if you
were a good-looking person like a
handsome debonair like oh-oh real
handsome uh-huh and you were a comedian
at the time when I started you quit or
anybody now yeah cuz you started off I
wanted to be a great actor you want to
be a leading role yeah that was your yes
Yeah right and you didn't happen to you
happy to build bad at me but not to you
you know it happened to somebody else
not you he's doing the game that's
bitter [ __ ] maybe bitter like
[ __ ] like me who stuck around
but that's we're in the process you did
but you did he was it was organic you
mean it your way
not that you won't mix in some of the
other standards that the industry say
you know some of them are understandable
someone you can understand but you still
gotta do it your way too
you gonna be here you ain't goin no way
we gonna be here when you got the goods
and you find me or whatever you may do
even if you wanna do comedy whatever you
your goal your you know your life's work
is you gonna be here but you got to do
it your way you gotta see it for what it
is
and saying you know what and that's why
you just called off all them damn dates
didn't that's what I'm trying to say and
not comparing yourself what you don't
have and somebody else has because it
doesn't make anything go crazy on me you
go crazy on your better side with a 40
hours oh yeah you got yourself a joint
and you're hanging out with a homie who
ain't [ __ ] telling you you're less about
who you better then yeah you go look at
the improv calendar or they hire re-wet
[ __ ] I just do that Bravo see
who they have that weak and white wack
and white comedian I will call up though
your brothers at yeah make it available
you telling me this guy's selling out is
doing their improv and you all right
then I will go back at that pay so it
was after this week right
this fool said when you're hanging out
with a homie that holy [ __ ] how do you
want with your angry Oh
copy the book a little bit let's go so
you just got a pretty much that's all
you gotta really do like I always had my
own mind like you got your own mind see
when you got your own mind you can't
just influenced me saying anything I'm
like that doughnut [ __ ] down in Selma
and people did least to save some - you
can't compare yourself to people you got
thank God for your blessings and like my
grandmother will say you gotta counted
oh joy whatever it is counted on joy and
stay off Instagram nip social media [ __ ]
you up soup you see it at dinner eating
comments don't everytime Araneta Acme
clay do not he said he will read the
comments right he will talk about some
big actor he was like okay we read a
article about some huge a mr. right he's
like okay here's the article man listen
to the comments
oh they were shredder Percy saving
comments don't read them comments see
them comments don't matter they behind
right the perfect thing they are bored
mages bully their keyboard and they're
not emotional about it at all so awfully
big saying is that if he was a hard
drive he would have quit a long time ago
know what I'm saying is that most of the
guys that got into comedy that were
good-looking they were looking at
stand-up comedy to be an actor first
laughing yeah they were they figure the
roles are gonna land that they're
sitting on the field and be the guy
that's a player yeah and he gonna happen
bro my focus was to be funny and make
people laugh yeah the money will come
later and it did it that's what I'm
trying to remember I taught a comedian
we told me a long time ago
for the money do it for the art and
they're all [ __ ] bro login no but
you gotta do it for that 90% hustle 2%
talent because if you do it for the okay
there is no money for a long time so you
be broke for the longest time so I mean
it's like how do you stay the best plan
ever heard man for this convenient great
hon you don't like to have I have a
corporate job well making them or making
them sit six figures a year he goes um
what he said he was making six figures a
year right I'll make it separately two
thousand a year yeah 20 years he quit to
do comedy yeah he was out he was yeah I
quit comedy man I was making it out he
said $125 but now he's off now I do it
for 50 bucks and two drinks and a [ __ ]
meal but that [ __ ] funny money
actually make 7/7 a little bit you're
working in a corporate job I haven't
made that a year it's our plan it's
tough but you're happy because you're
chasing your dream it's like American
Beauty when Kevin Spacey's like he quits
his job and he goes to MOCA we it's like
the best time of my life was when I was
flipping burgers a lot of gems come out
in those bad times like you be like
sitting down on the present they don't
you come with a great joke and at the
lowest point you're like what the [ __ ]
and you can't go cuz what if you quit
you might have been getting a huge
breaks an actress a might event tomorrow
might be easy that's Hollywood
load you something mommy do some good
[ __ ] but the matter visible that's what
keeps some people working actors when
they make one film every three years or
four years killing at this summer camp
game regressive was there right and he
never kills anywhere probably right
but accurate let's just fluffy was
telling me that this guy killed so hard
but he goes but he goes did he make you
laugh [ __ ] no but what were you laughs
what well he was they made me laugh what
do you say oh man I've only Hollywood
see this boy scout out pretty fuzzy
you're so fooled by that you know
because I've had great stats thinking
about this that would have made me yeah
that made me nothing it's got me laid
bro and I don't know the same loser on
the show doesn't even even a really
great set and a person who's on the cusp
of being famous though that won't do
anything it'll get you a meeting and you
got a kill in the meeting yah here she
stood me straight from the hip meeting
and then killing more media more Hill in
the pitch and I kill it the up fronts
and you still gotta be the moment you
slip they'll go people who are hilarious
on stage off stage they are [ __ ] you
know they're not even funny at all you
were a punch them in the face yes and
they're hilarious on stage they go on
radio they're [ __ ] mummies bro they
can sell one [ __ ] ticket yeah and it
was that but you know some people just
do not cut out for them if you like that
on radio and I don't even get that part
we're like I'll do press you know how
you do the press when you get all
serious he was such a great guest cuz I
mean I'm like how you gonna say on any
tickets if you come
he and you talk and you sniff we said I
know it's six o'clock in the morning
Barbara Walters interview with the
process although some we party way
people say they are let me talk the best
and I learned from this interview with
Margaret Cho
Gabriel se was doing a [ __ ] now he
was doing an interview and then Margaret
show called in because she had to
promote her show to she didn't know what
the hell we were talking about but after
every sentence she said Margaret show at
the Woburn theatre bothers show I'll be
there at ten o'clock
Margaret show will be there and they
[ __ ] over and over yes so what I do now
is the interview not going great so
awfully bright here you're doing they're
doing that well but you didn't hear was
I'm gonna be performing this Friday what
you haven't heard is this Friday I'm
going to be there any improvin so shows
are sold already well that's all but but
I changed it around man those DJ's
though yeah the ones who don't have
anything going they don't know like man
Calvin yeah they're like reading your
bio and that's all they have I hate that
there's no that you have to take over
the show you do want someone be like
well it maybe if it's just disrespectful
like oh you ain't even look at my [ __ ]
last night or before I can't well we
have Dominique here and that makes so it
says here and I'd be one to say cut this
[ __ ] it's too early in the morning to be
with your butt cheeks dis tight we got a
lawyer right here no more
Oh
os over so we put the blank something
that I don't understand whether away I'm
gonna tell you comical why I love [ __ ]
are you spending your money on this
conservative radio anger this talk radio
but I don't know our biggest we have a
lot listeners yeah but these listeners
don't go to your comedy show you ever
notice that there with your comedy shows
yeah stop wasting the money there but it
doesn't make sense that they don't spend
money with your demographic it's like
why would I be on a hard rock radio show
why am I on this show
yeah you know my demographic listens to
R&B music you supposed to get every RnB
you know what I mean and then do the
white station that if you do one the
tino station then do one white station
with the rock music but oh it'd be like
hard rock dominique in the market it's
gonna get you got a guy not only you but
you're they're lazy i came in like a
wrecking ball gags that's what they do
how about how about you're working with
with an owner a promoter he finds out
there's like some function somewhere
when our people is that for real estate
black people cuz there might be a lot of
messages over there right remember what
time i working at this club at chicago
uh and i'm bein together working there
he found out there's a swap meet was a
lot messy in the rat you know how about
we just go over there and walk around
and people recognized do you turn there
will be a show I said now I'm like I
know a lot of comics don't employ
language a
comics they go and they go in the city
early just to go to the mall and to do
all those kinds of things just to walk
around me talk to them no one saw
boobies at the new what's a full podcast
t-shirt yet oh they're going for $30 all
the money goes for a fundraiser oh gee
look at the purple one
yeah what's up podcast one more time
where people can find you on Instagram
um they could find me a Dominique comedy
I see om EDI my first name is spelled do
mi in IQ you eat that's on Twitter
that's on Instagram and if the old folks
on Facebook Dominique comedian and check
out my car cam Parker the game for the
funny is here with Dominique and friends
don't forget out we have we ever listen
to hear that he follows our podcast and
he's recovering alcoholic at covering
drunk oh and he draws us to eat to help
with recovery Oh Mario right yeah
process oh I don't know how I got into
following stories of t2 the
[ __ ] case oh yeah absolutely
right so I started following and I
followed him right to do what he done
right he's been given all that time he
about 30 something years that I said I
was talking about yeah my will can you
do any Murphy at the set of bail they
learned for right then I went to his
page and guess what the first guy I've
been following you for a while it was
Mario Bros Rosario Chris pockets so now
go legit everybody goal is it to
Dominic's podcast totally was subterra
heard Universal poof part as the worst
awful Parker family
sent you there thank you and I want
y'all to come on my pockets but I want
all y'all to come cuz I gotta go first
cuz I might have Lisa chimes in like we
said but no you have to go to one
meeting then you pitch us to pitch in
another meeting is another meeting
saying what the manager band [ __ ] drop
the [ __ ] P's and Q's Dominique Thank
You EE thank you I appreciate you guys